hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back I thought we would be
silent
I demand silence oh we've got issues
right off the bat I gotta get out there
I got a repair and we good but I'm gonna
try to uh I need to get my dog don't
have one of those I don't have one of
those but I need to get out there and I
need to repair some [ __ ]
which is gonna be a bit of a bear but
okay here we go oh I'm diving into this
one I didn't want to dive in nice
I gotta find these spots I had a fixin
quick go because there are threats
lurking everywhere in here boo Biscay
okay cut that one yay oh please please
please thank you thank you thank you ha
Bisky okay got that one does anybody
else see any damage
besides that big old piece of wreck over
there but that's not part of me so we
don't need to worry about that okay
looking pristine looking shiny all big
box bear you never look so good alright
I'm not seeing any more damage I think
all the damage registering being at the
top of it anyway so I think we're good
alrighty alrighty alrighty yeah yeah i
di di yeah yeah oh okay okay enough of
that welcome to the episode everybody
we've got two new recipes that we need
to be able to get and I need actually
keep up with my food intake which I
haven't been doing very much so I'm
gonna eat as much as I can and then come
where am i I am oke that that made sense
brawls gonna have to replace these bad
boys these guys are pretty well charged
up and I can't imagine that we chewed
through too many of one of these so
we're gonna flap that guy in there that
guys it's 75% place that chimney moose
Kishu buddy boo and this guy with you
why we're running silent you made me
piss my pants why don't you do that all
right labadie Labadie and then
Libertyville orbitty I don't know why
they keep attacking you there must be
something about this area that is
extremely aggravating to them but it's
also sad bye bye ok don't mind why I'm
out of breath or I changed clothes
that's not important it's only been
about 15 minutes I swear everything's
fine nothing's wrong everybody come up
with your own theories of what happened
down the comments below
but anyway so well San was we have two
new upgrades we got the sonar upgrade
and we got the fire suppression system
upgraded but before we do that I'm gonna
read some nice god dammit
stop I'm on silent running I thought
apparently I might not know I'm not on
some fine you know let's just move on
because it's only death here so I think
that is this the wreck that was
straddled across the - the - thingamabob
errs I think yeah oh hey you getting
freaky with that there recchia this is
the straddled one so the other one is
somewhere the logical deduction between
that one and this one is somewhere so
now back to the matter at hand
southwest Scott said mark if you hear a
Reaper roar run they have echolocation
and if you hear one the roar they know
where you are basically roar of Reaper
equal death by Reaper well I don't know
what good running would do for me I have
a funny feeling this is gonna up in my
death alone and everything is gonna go
to [ __ ] if that happens so the idea is
just not to get caught by a Reaper then
meta Giga said with all those youtube
user names on the lockers and the fact
that mark is more or less made his home
in the yellow Cyclops I guess you could
say that we all live in the Yellow
Submarine which in fact we do and it's
awesome and I love it and I'm so happy
to have you guys here with me and then
there's Jimmy John who said I think the
developers need to make some type of
battering ram just for mark because mark
thinks it's a good idea to just RAM
everything he sees intends to do so
without thinking which in turn causes
unnecessary damage to big box Barry hey
big box Barry's big old dick there's
nothing that I don't know why I'm never
the only thing that I like to Ram are
the freaking boomerangs that try to
sabotage my whole operation it's really
the boomerangs that are the goddamn
mastermind of this whole planet and it's
the boomerangs who invented the core
virus and it's the goddamn boomerangs
that are gonna be the death of me then
there's Benjamin Beaudry who I put his
Benjamin Bay mark looking for a wreck
just check out my life ooh snap self
burn and hey Benjamin it's okay
do you need someone to talk to we're all
here for you in this yellow submarine we
are all part of the same family so we
got one more thing that we need to do we
need to find one more one sweet
delicious delectable plan and I know
just where to find it so I'll be right
back once I get to the mouth of where I
need to go so we need to do is there are
a few more wrecks in the actual mountain
area that I need to find what I did is I
went around the outskirts of the
mountain but I didn't quite get to the
mountain range where the wrecks were now
I believe that I'm fundamentally on the
wrong side of the bat is a deep weird
that's an unnatural looking cave
formation I'm just gonna say that right
out that is it
that's a weird
my god damn it you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
thought you are Reaper just get out
there I hate you I hate you so much
God you scare the piss out of me don't
do that now that might just be that
might just be a pathway into the
underwater caverns of the mountain here
and I know that's a thing that happens
but god damn it doesn't need to be so
cataclysmic when it happens right I know
we're cavitating and I know that's bad
but I need to get over to the other side
of the mountain and I know there might
be Reapers nearby but I just need to
make speed here because I gotta get
there so I'll be back when things you
wanna kill they apparently what what
[ __ ] hell god damn it it needs to
stop that [ __ ] okay we're fine oh we
gotta go I don't know what we gotta do
you know what I'm gonna go silent
running is I got a bad feeling about
this area oh I got a bad feeling about
this area but I'm pretty sure if that's
the gun platform then down here way
below is what we need and this is 100%
Reaper territory
this is absolutely death territory right
here there's no way it's not morning
hold on I know buddy I know it's super
weird going through the ocean this
slowly calmly as if you're hiding from
some and you are but what I say by that
is they've really captivated the feeling
of being stalked in dangerous territory
by creatures that you can't even begin
to imagine the strength of just enormous
beasts of unimaginable strength that
just for external hold on they they just
want to kill you dead and that's all
they'll ever want to do so long as
they're able to ah what you you have to
me where did you come from
are you kidding me
beguiling Nikoli oh I don't know wait
but I'm gonna go away from it holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] oh that's gonna be question
mark I think oh no oh no no go after the
decoy Garf is an eco I need to go in
this wreck
[Music]
okay I'm here found it it's gonna go pop
out I'm fine
ignore the fact that we're listing
dangerously I am fine 100 percent a okay
just got to take my she's got a tank mr.
Pfister out there in case I need to go
mano-a-mano at this son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that guy okay but we gotta
go good number of things out here that
we could possibly use over that guy
doesn't come back have that please thank
you not that they need any more water
with how much I been pissing myself
these days that's always a useful skill
I saw that too
oh I saw that alright please have what I
need
yes decoy to above great ahem how does
that help me is it a better decoy tube
with better tube miss oh hi don't bother
me don't do it don't do it there's
nothing there for you it's a big yellow
submarine but it's nice it's a good guy
and just in case you get frisky with it
I guess
everything
five is uh I think there's a way to get
in this or is this is this a smaller
wreck that doesn't have this might not
have an entrance Hey hello warper was
that you war pee war pee whoa oh all
right I know who it does okay so I'm
gonna check that out in just a second
she's gonna grab these things cuz I've
forgotten what they are magnetite I
think I might need that I think I might
I'm not on it wasn't sure but I think I
might need that all right good
oh there's the warper huh so happy about
that okay all right you go you go after
yourself into the next dimension please
Hey okay all right I'm almost out of out
to I'm gonna make a pit stop inside mr.
Pfister and then I'm gonna go into this
place and try to find the last data box
I wish I didn't come here I've only got
one more decoy with which to destroy
that [ __ ] that sounds weird want to
say it like that but I'm gonna come into
that Millea one decoy with which left to
destroy that [ __ ] all right anything
in here uh-huh
just more water oh that's another data
box okay psych off shield generator Oh
it said shield generator on it I've
assumed that I got that I'm assuming
that I got what I came for him then I'm
gonna get stuff for chowder yeah oh how
do I get out of here wait where am I
where am I
there I am okay let's get back in mr.
Fisher and let's get the fur G out of
here cuz we made progress today already
we're doing great
yeah life is good life is good life is
good life is good life is good life is
good life is good life is good oh you
are dark Hey
young systems leave attention what do
you mean some systems require okay okay
thank you for the notification I think
I've got a lot of [ __ ] in me uh and I
need to drop this off because I am NOT
doing well but we got it we got this
shield generator I don't know how to
make it but I we got it I guess good for
us
I'm gonna start putting [ __ ] in here
because I don't have the patience to
sort through it got so much water now
maybe I shouldn't drink my piss but are
you know I'm a god groaning taste for it
I guess all right so I'm gonna go back
up I'm gonna eat more fruit and then
we're getting out of here I should have
this yes decoy to upgrade oh we can get
more decoys that's actually good to
wiring kids in copper wire we're gonna
get that once we get more copper which
we don't have Power Cell advanced wiring
kit Power Cell you're a knight I have
almost all those I think I can even make
the I can make that right now which I'm
gonna do before I go off because if that
[ __ ] wants to tussle with me he's
gonna get a face full of markiplier if
you know what I'm talking about
table yes okay we got it okay we got
that we're gonna make the computer chip
what did I just put away that I needed
advanced wiring kit gold that's what I
need the advanced wiring kit we're gonna
make this good I am aware of this fact
big box Barry you'll okay so here we go
and then BAM we got a shield on us which
means we're gonna survive maybe and I
realize now I just realized we can only
put so many of these upgrades into big
box Barry
like legitimately we can oh we only have
so many spots we've got oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
dude I don't know how that's gonna work
ah that seems to be a problem but we got
the shield and oh that's where the fire
extinguisher is which I'm gonna need so
I'm assuming I don't need thee I don't
need generally I don't need to just
saying that out loud I don't think we
need the fire suppression system because
I trust these magic fingers right here
and I know for a fact that we're gonna
be able to get out of here okay I'm
gonna actually I'm gonna one more thing
before we do that I'm going
- I know we just turned off silent
running which is I have a funny feeling
that's a bad idea but it's okay because
I'm gonna go over here I'm gonna put the
load the decoy in the tube we're gonna
get out of here and everything is gonna
be hunky-dory
okay so we got to decoy in the tube and
we should have shields we should do we
have shields we do oh okay rizzoli
silently silently it is frickin
nighttime but I don't trust myself to
sleep just yet because if I sleep I
could die a horrible death from Reapers
oh I don't like this I don't like this
at all I don't like this at all
the reaper is there in the darkness and
I can't see it we're just gonna try to
breach the surface and hope for the best
cuz if we don't we're gonna die oh okay
okay then we're good
everything seems to be fine thus far I
think we're good okay Oh thankfully we
don't need to lose this goddamn shield
so I'm getting out of here I know we're
cavitating but I am [ __ ] breaching
and I'm getting out of here where's the
goddamn ship I don't even know where
that is anymore
I can't see a goddamn thing where is
everybody how do I get this turned
around oh there it is okay we just got
to go this way skirting along the
surface hopefully no Reapers are gonna
be coming this high up oh my god so far
out I didn't even realize I was that far
out from the ship [ __ ] dude
oh my god okay but either way we got
what we need we've got the shield
upgrade that looks like this holy hell
I don't know how long that lasts and I
don't know how much power it uses but
supposedly it uses a lot of power and
supposedly it lasts not long enough if I
had to guess
and there's the containment platform the
quarantine containment platform a
majestic site protruding from the
shadows the fog lifts and we see the
devastating effect that it had on the
aurora bone or she conquered I'm well
aware there were cavitating ship but
anyway so we got everything that we need
I believe I believe we have all of the
upgrades necessary at least not crafted
but we have all the recipes for the
upgrades necessary to be able to fully
max out big box berry and hopefully that
means that we're not going to have to
worry about things attacking us we're
going to be able okay so that uses 5% of
my current level of power and if I can
get more ion crystals that means I can
replace more of those Power Cells with
ion power cells and that's going to be
better for us in the long run but it
also means that we're going to have
plenty of energy with which to do what
we need to do but the bad thing is if I
use that shield too much that's going to
negate the surplus of energy that I get
from the excess heat efficiency module
that I have and if I need to use more
space I'm not going to be able to use
that heat efficiency module and I'm not
going to be able to recycle my power
into an endless supply which means that
I will have to stop off regularly I
don't know if they intended it to be
this way
good but that's just the way that it is
right now so thank you everybody so much
for watching I'm all out of time to this
episode I'm gonna go back to my base
down in the grand reef and I'm going to
use that as a staging area to be able to
fully upgrade my Cyclops and then carry
back down into the depth of hell from
whence the sea dragon comes and I know
that if I think the Reaper
is a bad enemy to tussle with I know for
a fact the sea dragon is so much worse
course huh so thanks again everybody for
watching as always I will see you in the
next video bye
[Music]